- They're kind of like
dinosaurs, but not in a good way.
Just in a terrifying way,
like they could revert at any time.
(mysterious music and birds cawing)
- I don't like birds,
whether they're small or big,
or whatever they're doing,
if they're just sitting there or flying,
I do not like them at all.
- I have immediate fear of them.
- They're messy, they shit on everything.
- The weird feet.
- I'm kind of scared that they're gonna
just attack every single human being.
- [Voiceover] There is a
surprise element to this video.
(ding)
- Please don't bring in a bird.
(groans) What's that noise?
- Is it in front of my face?
- [Voiceover] Not yet.
- What, not yet?
[Voiceover] Open your eyes.
- [Blonde Woman] You can do it. (laughs)
- (gasps) Oh!
- [Man] Oh my God.
- (gasps) Oh my God!
- Oh my God.
- Oh my God!
(gasps quietly)
- Oh my God, there are three of them!
- It's ducks.
It's ducks.
- Oh my God, they're so yellow!
- Hi.
- Hi, hey.
(woman laughs)
- It's a baby.
- No! No!
Don't! Don't!
- I think mine's shitting on my hand.
My hand feels moist.
- Ah!
- Oh my God, holy shit!
They're so cute!
- I'm so not scared of these ones.
- I'm your mother now.
- Oh my God, look at the little wings.
Oh, the bugs.
- [Pink Haired Woman] Is it soft?
- As long as I look at it this way,
and I can't see his eyes
or his beak or his claws,
he's super cute!
- It's kind of awkward though.
'Cause I feel I've eaten a lot of these,
and it's really bad.
I'm like, "Sorry!"
It's true, people eat ducks!
- [Woman] But you don't have to eat ducks!
- Dude, I'm really sorry!
I never thought I would
see you eye to eye.
- Oh!
- That noise!
- He's making a little wiffle noise.
- I can look at it and I
can appreciate its cuteness,
but I can't carry it.
No. (laughs)
- I feel like a good duck mother.
- I feel like a horrible duck father.
- [Blonde Woman] This
doesn't count as a bird.
It's not flapping in my face.
It's not pooing on my car.
- This is the best surprise
that I think I've ever had.
- His eyes are still
really freaking me out
when I look at them.
- Yeah, I like birds.
They're cool.
- See, these are what raptors became.
If they were bigger -
- [Blonde Woman] Oh my God, chill buddy.
- They would eat me.
This does not change how
I feel about birds at all.
- I am still a bit freaked out.
- I definitely like birds
a lot more after today.
- After looking at a duck in the eyes,
I'm gonna try not to eat duck now.
- Hate birds.
Like fluffy things.
- (sings Lion King opening song)
♫ I love ducks. ♫
I just wanna be a duck queen,
and just be surrounded by ducks
for the rest of my life, to be honest.